so just out of curiosity like by rays of
hands has anyone here heard of tarpy
before don't raise your hand if I just
told you about it okay so we got one
person that's actually more than I was
expecting
um that's actually that's actually
pretty good
um but that's okay like the it's not a
product for you so tarpie uh is we do uh
readership analytics for news Publishers
so this is like a dashboard that shows
how many people are on your website at
any given time and sort of each entry in
that row is a news article maybe an
opinion piece or some sort of breaking
news and if you're on the editorial
board of some big news publisher you
want to know what people on your website
are reading and where they're coming
from if they're coming from email Google
Facebook Twitter uh whatever
uh this is a slide that I stole from our
marketing department
um presumably it's supposed to say that
we're impressive uh we work with some
logos you may have seen some news you
may have read uh
a lot of page views six continents turns
out no news Publishers and and excuse me
in Antarctica uh you've tried but uh
this Park's Market uh but so a lot of a
lot of things being published uh there's
an example of a news article we're going
to talk about a little bit in this talk
this says uh AMD closes a record ship
deal with uh buying some companies
xilinx uh which is you know an example
of a typical news article you may have
read
and if you think about this sort of
going on this dashboard here uh it would
be some sort of Entry that has the title
of the page uh saying how many people
are on the page but there's a lot more
that goes into this article than just
sort of the headline of the article you
know there's there's sort of uh Primary
people being referenced AMD and xilinx
there's uh you know secondary
organizations like nvidia's referenced
even though they're not party to the
specific event you know they're
reference within the content of the
article
um
and so this is a pipeline that I'm going
to talk about today in my talk it tries
to read through all of the content on
this page uh yeah take a photo the
slides will be online it's okay uh yeah
yeah so uh we try to read through the
content of this page and try and extract
a lot more knowledge than just sort of
the title and see uh what can we
actually say about what's being
discussed in this article the idea being
that we can go back to this dashboard
and say instead of sort of saying how
many people are uh on one specific
article how many people are reading
articles about this topic or that topic
um so I'll start off sort of in the
upper left hand corner here is it left
okay definitely left I
um so uh in the upper left hand corner
we have sort of a queuing system that
comes in as we're sort of uh seeing new
pages being published and we have this
uh consumer that reads messages from
this message queue
um and it just uses the regular python
requests package in order to uh go
request the HTML just as you would and
if it's able to visit the page it saves
the HTML to S3 and you know pushes the
URI and S3 along
um and so what does this look like this
is an example of some HTML if you ever
go to a web page on your browser and
right click it and say view Source this
is what it looks like
this specifically is an example from a
CNN article which is maybe a little bit
prettier than some examples you might
see
there's some helpful metadata that's
included along with the HTML
um so there's sort of three different
standards you can use or at least that
are sort of widely used there's Micro
Data which is an HTML standard uh open
graph Facebook uses to uh sort of get
some idea of what's going on in the
article in Json LD so if we go back to
this example uh if you maybe squint a
little bit I wasn't sure how big the
projector would be when I made this
slide but if you sort of squint a little
bit you can see the meta name some of
them start with sort of OG that says OG
title and that's the title of the
article OG description it includes a
description about the article uh OG
image and it has a link to sort of the
headline image in the article and some
of them might include sort of the full
body text as a metadata element in the
article
um but oftentimes they don't and it's
sort of a very difficult problem if you
think about just looking at the HTML of
a page and trying to figure out which
text on the page is sort of the text you
read and not sort of like a footer maybe
their privacy policy cookies or
something like that
um and so there are lots of different
python packages that will try to do this
if you sort of give it some HTML
document try and figure out which text
is actually the content of the page
um
you may have heard of them a few
different ones we tried out a whole
bunch of them uh there are lots of
different uh comparison and benchmarks
online so if you try to find like sort
of the best uh package to do it lots of
people have published uh uh scoring
methodologies this one I thought was
particularly special
um so I included in my talk this one is
a software vendor who sells a software
product called Auto extract and they
sort of published a benchmark comparing
themselves to a bunch of Open Source
Solutions and sort of unsurprisingly
they found that their solution was the
best they also list a free and open
source alternative that performs very
similarly
um so that's what we use
um so thank you for that
um so if you give it the HTML of this
Reuters article it will sort of spit out
the text of the article uh nice uh so
Spacey you may have heard of before
uh who's here supportive Stacy okay so
much more people have heard of space
that's okay
um but Spacey I hope you all know uh
fantastic for NLP they will give you uh
uh ner pre-trained models and sure
enough if you just just plug the text
from the prior Library into Spacey it
will give you a fantastic list of all of
the entities as well as sort of what
type of entities it thinks it is uh so
you can see the first one Advanced Micro
Devices I think is an organization a bit
further down Lisa stew with things as a
person
and immediately there are a few problems
with this
um you know first of all you can see
several entities are sort of duplicated
so you can see amd's listed a few times
it's listed in a different name so AMD
and Advanced Micro Devices Lisa Sue is
is referenced by sort of her full name
and then later on as just just by her
last name the company that's being
acquired xilinx is referenced by xilinx
Incorporated xilinx and the sort of odd
stock picker format that I'm not sure
what the DOT
um there are many approaches uh to try
and solve this problem
uh many approaches to interesting
linking are sort of disambiguation
um the first one I think is probably the
most common is people trying to use like
these knowledge graphs
um
so wikidata actually has an open an API
for this
um this is kind of like a weird form of
SQL if anyone sort of Sparkle before uh
it's for like querying graph data so you
can say sort of give me all of the
people where the name looks like Albert
Einstein and maybe you can include some
information you're able to abstract from
the article as well with that query to
try and uh narrow it down it's a little
bit slow if you think about how big a
Knowledge Graph can be and you think
about the number of entities that may
appear in sort of all news articles
appearing across the news you know
millions and millions of entities every
day if it takes one second to run this
query you know there's only so many
seconds in a day you're going to run
behind
um so that's a little bit slow in
beddings I'm sure are very common so if
you try to make a vector that represents
how that word is being used in the text
um interestingly there's there's a an
open source Library called Wikipedia
Tubac that tries to vectorize sort of a
word and then tries to find Wikipedia
articles that have similar embeddings so
this is an example where if you try to
get the word Vector for Tesla
um
and then find the Wikipedia articles
that are most similar you might find
Nikola Tesla or the company
and so which of the two is it
um so the idea is that you sort of
include words that are used uh in the
text as well uh to disambiguate it so
here you can see on the left you have uh
Elon and Tesla and if you try to get the
Wikipedia Vector that is closest to
those two word vectors you're able to
sort of clearly get the company and if
you include bird uh you get Nikola Tesla
now you might be confused that's because
this example is a few months old before
Elon tried to buy the bird company
so the guy Nikola Tesla was uh
was interested in pigeons but the that
was not I have jokes later on that
wasn't supposed to be one of the jokes
but it became you know an anecdote
moment uh leading up to this talk uh
anyways so the downside is that uh we'll
one one downside of this is that if the
words are sort of totally unrelated and
only make sense together uh it performs
particularly poorly so new in York are
words that really take on entirely
different meanings when they're combined
you think of it similarly with names
maybe like George Washington or
something you know George and Washington
are a much different meaning than when
combined the other downside is that also
you know doing a large Vector lookups
and comparisons you know are
particularly slow you really we really
found that we needed something much
faster in order to try and run this on
every SD in all of the news articles
every day
uh and so one thing that uh is
referenced a couple of times if you if
you look up sort of the academic
literature for this as sort of a very
basic approach uh is to look at
Wikipedia data so this is the Wikipedia
article for the central processing unit
and it says many major vendors such as
IBM Intel and AMD and this text AMD here
is a little hyperlink uh to the AMD
Wikipedia article and so sure enough uh
this is an interesting example of all of
the times that AMD is sort of the
Wikipedia article is
is a reference
uh AMD so uh there's actually another
open source python package called in
show and uh you may not know this but it
turns out Wikipedia dumps all of their
uh databases online every two weeks at
dumps.wikimedia.org and you can go and
download them there are only about 50
gigabytes uh and kenshow has made this
python package that will download it and
process it into these nice little CSV
files specifically for uh natural
language processing tasks
um so this is an example of the output
of that Library if you download it and
run it
um this is specifically a bunch of rows
in the CSV having to do with Joe Biden
so it has sort of three rows here the
anchor text itself so the text of that
hyperlink the target page ID and the
account so you can see in the first row
here it's saying that
6366 times this page uh one four five
four two two has been referenced uh with
the text of Joe Biden and you can see
these are all the times at that one
specific page has been referenced as
that thing and uh you can see sort of
all the different names in natural Pros
that this Wikipedia page may be
referenced as
um so you know
going back to this example with AMD once
you have this link
um to
amd's main Wikipedia page you can also
link it to uh
the wikidata knowledge graph so this is
the wikidata entry for AMD
and one thing that's nice about this is
that it also includes all of the known
aliases for this entity so it has AMD
Advanced Micro Devices
um you know ones that are perhaps
somewhat obvious but also some that are
not obvious like team red it would be
much harder to find sort of via string
matching or something but if you're able
to get all the known aliases for the
Wikipedia page that's very nice uh this
is Joe Biden's wikidata entry uh you can
see there can sometimes be like a ton of
different aliases for something and uh
you can go through and match all of them
uh so if you apply this technique to our
Reuters article from earlier uh you can
see it sort of works pretty well so up
here at the top we see Lisa Sue is sort
of the base text and one reference we
find to it is Sue
um and we have sort of marked down the
different positions within the article
so the 111th word
excuse me 155th word the 239th word
lower down we have xiling as a reference
silence Incorporated we have the base
Tech amb in a reference Advanced Micro
Devices Incorporated
um so it works pretty well it's not
always perfect so just further down from
this article we have Taiwan something
about their manufacturing company uh
it's referenced as uh co-limited and it
turns out in its Wiki data entry it's
sort of spelled out Company Limited uh
and tsmc is not a known Alias of that
specific string of text you could maybe
do some kind of fuzzy string matching
but exact string matching doesn't
totally play out there's also this
reference to xilinx by what appears to
be a stock ticker but with DOT o I'm
actually not sure what that means maybe
it's like dot oh if it's unlisted we've
got some hedge fund people in here last
night
what oh dot o means it's from the NASDAQ
that doesn't really follow you'd think
they'd have like dot in or something
or something no
one would one would think they could
have some kind of top level domain
system
I don't know maybe they could get a
better registry
um another thing this is the Wikipedia
page for the cynic uh this is the
concept of a senate uh so oftentimes you
might see things in the news that say
something like the Senate today voted
that uh and maybe depending on the
context if you're reading an American
thing you might think oh well it's
referring to the United States Senate or
you know some Senate in the in in the
Eurozone or something uh but it turns
out Wikipedia the most common way the
most common Wikipedia article that's
referred to as the Senate is the concept
of a senate uh which is wrong in this
context it's not the end of the world
but
um the other thing is this is the
Wikipedia page for ideological bias uh
so it has this quote here Wikipedia has
an internal policy which states that
articles must be written from a neutral
point of view uh I don't know if any of
you guys have ever read the news before
oftentimes news is not written from a
neutral point of view oftentimes it has
a strong opinion and they'll reference
people as sort of nicknames or or
derogatory names that aren't listed on
their Wikipedia page
um there are sometimes what works
fantastic though so this is the this is
some news article talking about college
football projections and it's able to
catch uh uh the names of schools to
references uh to their mascots so the
Green Wave I think is the name of maybe
not a mascot but name of the sports team
is a reference to Tulane and Ohio State
is the Buckeyes
I think this is a Tech Conference
uh
so there is this other issue of trying
to figure out which of these are
actually important so Spacey finds 36
entities in this article uh 14 after you
link them together but this is a
relatively short article some long
articles may have hundreds or thousands
of entities referenced
um you know if you think about some like
long News expose you know might be
talking about a whole bunch of different
people and a whole bunch of different
organizations some of them sort of only
uh
for for a short moment uh and for that
we use this uh algorithm called SK this
is the article uh that um computer
science professors wrote uh about it and
it's pretty interesting so if you give
it sort of the positions within the
article of all of the entities it will
try to use how often they're referenced
uh how high up in the article or in the
document they reference and how close it
is to sort of other important entities
in order to figure out which ones are
actually sort of important to the
document itself
um and so if you apply that again to our
article here A and B is sort of the
score of value is how important it is so
AMD hits a score of 152 xilinx with the
score of 14 Lisa sue the CEO of AMD gets
a score of four
an arm gets a score of three so here you
can kind of quantify which of these
things are actually important to the
content of the article and you can sort
of figure out which ones are just
reference and pass a
um so this is the uh Wikipedia part of
the pipeline so we have a system that
goes to the Wikipedia dumps downloads
them all and then stores the uh results
in S3 interestingly if you think about
you know what is a data set of all of
the hyperlinks in Wikipedia and the
number of times that a specific string
of X is used it's sort of less than five
gigabytes with all the aliases so it's
small enough that you can just store it
in Ram load as a data frame and then
just do data frame lookups and it's very
quick uh so you can do it on a lot of
entities on all of your news articles if
you're interested in doing that
um key terms are something else that we
look at so chartbeat has a text
processing library that was written by
Dr dewild while he was at trophy uh and
text to see it calls itself NLP before
and after Spacey
um so one part of it is it has an
implementation of the position rank
algorithm uh that tries to pull what we
call key terms out of an article and so
if you apply it to this article it's
able to not just sort of get uh entities
but sort of add some context to the
terms so we have not just sort of
Advanced Micro Devices but the
semiconductor designer
prices the CEO of AMD a record ship
industry deal a xilinx acquisition and
field program
Mable um
so it's also November right now and I
want to be topical in this talk and
demonstrate how key terms work
um so I looked up
uh some some topical topics uh so here
we have real terms that were used by
news agencies pumpkin spice lattes
people who are pumpkin spice fans uh
people writing news articles about deep
fried pumpkin spice lattes
um right now we're in the booming
pumpkin spice season there are people
who are Bonafide pumpkin spice experts
writing about bad pumpkin spice products
like pumpkin spice Foods
um right so moving on from key terms uh
there's uh these uh International groups
for news agencies uh iptc is one of them
and they're really concerned about
building these category uh schemes or uh
pieces of content online I believe it's
mostly for selling ads like people want
to be able to sell their ads on articles
about health and labor but they don't
want it to be on an article about sort
of war or something
um and so they spend a bunch of time
building these sort of categorization
schemes and then news Publishers will
care sort of how many people are reading
my articles about health how many people
are reading my articles about the
environment
um and so this is a pretty classic
categorization problem if you think
about sort of building a model that will
predict whether or not a news article is
in one category another based on the
text in it I think the biggest problem
for us here was
well how are you going to get a whole
bunch of labeled examples of these news
articles just from scraping the text
um so one thing we tried to do was we
use mechanical Turf which maybe some of
you have heard of uh where you
pay people some amount of money via AWS
to read a piece of
label as one thing or another we tried
doing that uh we ended up getting very
poor quality data people just kind of
selecting one thing to move on to the
next task
um we tried intern uh where you just
have an intern sit down and label
everything this was terrible mostly
because I was an intern at the time so I
was just sitting there labeling
everything uh and it's really slow if
you think about you know how many uh
pieces of text you need for your deep
learning model uh you might as well just
have me sit there 24 7 labeling all of
them as they're published
um can we use Wikipedia for that too
turns out yes so Wikipedia also has a
news system uh called Wiki news where
they will publish news articles uh
little summaries of news events uh and
they have a categorization scheme uh
it's not the same as the ones that other
news Publishers care about but what's
faster than labeling a bunch of Articles
uh building a categorization mapping
from Wikipedia categorization schemes to
your own categorization scheme
um and this tends to work pretty well
for England so this is a graph that's
also stolen from Wikipedia showing uh
Wikipedia edits in various languages as
you can see at the top there in blue is
English turns out almost half of
Wikipedia edits are in English
um
so translation uh you may have heard of
uh you can translate from one uh
language into another and a lot of cloud
providers have paid services that will
translate an article or sort of
translate some document from some given
language into another language
um there's a photo of a Lamborghini if
you think about how much it costs to pay
AWS or gcp to translate all of the news
articles being published every month uh
into English it would cost about one of
these every month
uh or about one of these uh pixelated
images uh but it is included in my
talking through so I don't really know
uh I want to add a teacher
um
okay so Libre translate is an open
source project uh they sell they don't
sell
uh they offer a uh uh an API sort of a
pre-packaged Docker image uh that serves
an API endpoint where you give it some
string of text and it will translate it
into something like
um It's relatively slow off the bat
actually it takes about 30 seconds for
cpu-based translations uh so when we
were playing around with this we
actually noticed that it powered under
the hood by Argos translate which is
another open source package which runs
off of ctranslate 2 and C translate two
interestingly has GPU support uh this is
kind of a cool chance for us at Sharpie
to jump in and do a small open source
contribution to turn on uh and to enable
gpu-based translations uh in Libre
translate and it turns out it doing it
on CPU rather than CPU lowers the main
occupation time in our testing came
about 30 seconds to about five seconds
uh and so with that this is an example
of a Japanese article I can't read
Japanese but if you plug it into Libre
translate and run it for five seconds on
a GPU it will spit out a curling final
quick report Japan X UK gold medal the
final of the Olympics the first in Japan
curling history curling women in Japan
representative will play against the
United Kingdom with gold medals so a
little bit of a janky grammar is not the
best translation but it's just enough
that if you train a machine learning
model on Wiki news uh it can look at
that and say that's clearly sport
that was a big reveal I was hoping for
more of her actions uh
uh so sure enough uh back to our like
pipeline overview we have the Libre
translate API in there that we can pull
um so we have some Reuters article here
and in addition to just having the
headline we know sort of the body text
we know the key entities which are AMD
and xilinx we have some idea of the key
terms which are it's talking about this
record industry deal and we know the
iptc category economy business and
so a lot more of a complete view with
that we export that out to S3 and then
we load it via snow pipe into snowflake
um and so what can you do with this data
this is a thing that we try to do at the
end of the year with the economist uh
this is a graph of sort of the big news
topics of the world uh by their
readership and engagement so you can see
here in the bottom left side you have so
it's a little bit of small text
uh but sure enough the bottom events are
capital Riot Trump uh impeached again
and the Biden inauguration and then you
can see maybe a few sort of sift through
you can see your favorite news event uh
during the 2021 news cycle
all the way up to
the news events
that have
um
some lessons learned from building out
this pipeline web data is incredibly
unruly I think if you think about doing
something like test driven development
maybe you heard that in your CS classes
or something you thought okay what's
this data supposed to look like I'm
going to write some unit tests for
processing data that's supposed to look
like that if you're trying to process
web data this will almost assuredly not
work uh the internet is like the wild
west anyone can do anything with me
there and if there's one thing they're
not going to do it's like follow spec so
lots of people will list their data uh
in these metadata standards incorrectly
and if you write code that's used to
process it incorrect or correctly it
will sort of not work uh so one thing we
did was just look at the logs read
through all the errors and then try to
see how can we change our system such
that it will work maximally uh and raise
the fewest errors
um don't underestimate the power of a
good heuristic
there are lots of machine learning
Solutions you can read about in academic
literature for doing entity linking and
in disambiguation
um
in in our experience they sort of don't
perform so much better than quick
heuristics that are sometimes wrong but
in in general can provide okay
performance uh or are less computational
costs uh and make sure to check open
source offerings like uh hopefully one
thing you maybe took away from this talk
is that there are lots of great open
source projects out there
um people have put fantastic things on
GitHub and you can use them in your
pipelines to read news articles
and that's the end
all right thank you John uh we now we
have time for questions and I am going
to hand you the mic
um so I will come out with him like uh
why don't we start with you in the front
because it's close to me
thanks for the talk uh quick question
just to verify how are you doing the
entity lookup so you end up using you
can show that you've described yeah so
can show I think they released like one
preset version of all of Wikipedia
processed in 2019 but the python code is
all on GitHub you can download it and
run it to sort of get these csvs as
output and the csvs if I sort of go back
a couple of slides
and you remember like all the great
jokes I told them all these slides
um you know one of them specifically is
like the CSV output that is the anchor
text Target page ID account once you
have that Target page ID you can sort of
do a join onto a mapping of the
Wikipedia page IDs to wikidata entries
to get to All the known aliases for that
case yeah and I wanted to jump to that
slide precisely for my question with uh
no no this this one yeah leave it
so the Biden uh the Biden links to only
one uh Wikipedia articles is this will
it be a unique uh occurrence in this
lookup table right it will be maybe
[Music]
that's the Wikipedia sort of index ID
for the wiki data item and there is like
an official uh
so I have there's a slide so there is
like a there is like a general Wikipedia
page for go buy it in the person and his
ID uh is with the CFA ID you can look up
Patrick over
ID is one four five four two two yeah so
if I if I search by it and buy this
lookup I would only find this one four
five four two two and nothing else you
will find other references other
references were the same Biden will so
you'll have multiple IDs for just Biden
yeah right you take the most common one
because I can go on Wikipedia right now
I can say I don't know any wild thing I
want to say in my edit but then say you
know Joe Biden and Link the Wikipedia
page for something entirely unrelated
um but in general like that you want to
go with is like 6000 is higher than one
or
five thousand of course yeah thank you
all right other questions I'll come see
you in the back
um so the Sharpie slide could you go
back to that demo page and I think a
joke that you told that didn't get any
credit was the headline examples and I'm
like really interested in maybe you
could read the third one out loud
oh stay tuned for our concert live score
no the fourth one sorry the first one oh
Olympic volleyball hopefully hopeful
arrested for spiking punch oh that's a
good one
that's a good one I also stole this from
the marketing department
um
so I didn't realize that joke was there
but good for calling it out hopefully
someone this is recorded So hopefully
someone I try to eat just watch that and
they were like wow great job did
somebody just bump against the lips oh
that was a great question um how about
you
um I'm interested in have you
done something on which is the main
actor of the new I mean maybe a company
is suing another company for some reason
and have you done something on which is
the good part and about part of
something like that that's a good
question we
first reaction
I wonder how many
taking an action on another entity I
feel like there's probably a lot that
are
I don't know I'm trying to think maybe
more like General in nature but it's
very possible that's probably a good
idea
sorry were you able to use the
out-of-box spacing models or did you
have to do any training to improve
entities or entity recognition yeah so
we used the out of box like space the
ner models uh the categorization thing I
talked about was us training a text
categorization model
uh
I was curious about your entity uh
disambiguation and resolution in
different languages so what happens
there are you able to source that does
that come from Wikipedia
right yeah so there are other like
language wikipedias the downside is that
um uh you know they they're they're far
more sparse you can still do uh an ER
via Spacey Spacey I think supports
something like uh
I want to say 22 languages or something
it's quite big uh you can't use like
English Wikipedia data to disambiguate
it we have looked a little bit about
like well
um maybe we can use that language as
Wikipedia for it um but I think it's a
bit harder because there's not as strong
any other questions
thank you it was a great talk so I just
have a question like
uh if you do an ER have you thought
about like a reducing the scope for the
ner for example for sports if you
identify these articles about sports and
then the entity will be much less and
then you will have much better uh
Precision on the ER have you done that
kind of like a categorized
that's a good point uh we have not
specifically done that
um uh maybe not specifically with uh
scope on like towards categorization but
one thing uh we're we're really
concerned about and we wanted to step
away from is even in cases where we
might be able to leverage sort of like
other uh perhaps like use of how an
entity is referenced in the news article
um we try to stay away from it because
there's a lot of risk if you sort of are
able to reference it to something that's
sort of like crazy Rock so I'm trying to
think of an example of like maybe
there's someone named Tom that's being
referenced a lot by sort of some news
agency or something if you say well this
news article is writing a lot about Tom
it might be this one as well well it's
much more likely that outside of the
scope of a single news article there's a
lot more
uh entities named so your your your need
for disambiguation As you move to like a
scope level I think
expand significant memory
all right any more questions
I have a question actually it's more of
a business question
um
can you use this like collate by topic
and then share with uh each Publisher's
competitors
that's a good question
uh like
show it to them my understanding is that
there's significant need like every news
publisher wants to say like well how am
I doing compared to
my competitors and they'll sort of like
name their competitors but then if you
say okay that's cool I'll tell you what
if we put the five of you together and
we'll all show you each other's data
they'll say well no you can't show my
data but show me their data uh and so I
think there's maybe like a little bit of
a chicken or the egg thing but